what did you mean when you talked about
the tragedy of the male sex drive
uh yes well
uh i'm using the tragedy and the term
uh
in the more advanced literary criticism
arthur miller had a famous uh i say a
tragedy is not just something bad
happening
uh but it's sort of a fatal flaw in
yourself and you're striving for
something great
but because of the flaw you
you fail he said uh he said in a sense
tragedy although it has unhappy ending
it's more uplifting than comedy this
comedy sort of looks at people's faults
and foibles and bad things and so
and so describe it as a tragedy i'm not
saying it's it's a calamity i'm not even
saying that it's that it's a bad thing
but
uh it seems
doomed
uh
to falling short of its of its desires
that men were just instilled to
want
more sex than they're likely to get
um
i think a
while ago we
cited some research by one of my
colleagues who surveyed her first year
college students of
well if you if you wanted
uh how many people would you like to go
to bed with for the rest of your life
assuming it was all up to you don't
worry about diseases or laws or
pregnancy or anything is just you know
to experience sex how many people would
you like to do it and
the average for the women was was two
and a half
and the average for the men was 64.
now with that there's a lot of
disappointment ahead for those young men
um but it's it's true now it must be
said a lot of the men just said i'd like
to have one presumably they hadn't had
any yet
and do you think well if i could get one
that would be perfect but the man has
had one kind of wishes he would have two
or three and manus had three maybe
wishes for six or seven and i said ten
may wish for
fifteen
and uh you know i've known men who had
over 100 sex partners and they were
still wishing for more
um
and that kind of again suggests this
tragic flaw aspect
nature did not design you to be
satisfied that
i've had my sex and it was great and i'm
done with that
no and
having it more makes you think of it
more so it stimulates more desire to try
new things and
do new things with different people or
the same people
um
so
in that sense it seems
uh
somewhat doomed to frustration and
um
i've also been thinking in in terms of
the uh what i mentioned before
uh that uh we're talking about how women
shaped men
i think women probably shaped men toward
higher sex drive
as i said other apes they don't take
fatherhood seriously at all the idea
that you should provide food for your
children
that would seem ridiculous to them and
especially doing it on a regular basis
over many years and even to the mother
of those children who after all is just
some gorilla you had sex with a couple
years ago uh no no that that would seem
ridiculous to them
and yet human males do this routinely so
when that was evolving
there were probably plenty of men who
had the same outlook that your average
gorilla does and say come on i have to
work twice as hard to produce twice as
much food every day and give half of it
to this wife baby uh that seems nuts and
uh
well those men took themselves out of
the gene pool right
if they didn't want to play along uh and
put up with uh supporting the women and
uh
you know
um i've known many women who are
delightful and
fine people and so on but inevitably
some of them are difficult and neurotic
and unpleasant and and all that and
uh well what's to make the man make the
commitment and
stay with them too they need they need
providers to support them and their
children
and the desire for sex is a strong thing
and so
i i'm suspecting that
the human male population has a higher
sex drive
than the animals we evolved from and
that they were specifically selected not
in those terms but
[Music]
the women would reproduce with the men
who wanted sex enough to
stay committed and
put up with whatever the woman's demands
and problems are
so
a high sex drive would
would be selected there
uh it's it's ironic because of course
women complain about men being too
sexually motivated and uh although they
also complain when men stop making
advances and and so on it's uh
it's it's a balance to strike it's a
difficult bargain you know
that i'm not a young man trying to
figure out what the rules are today as
they keep changing what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
oh